good morning John it's time for another
bizarre beast this is a project I'm
doing over the next 12 months where
every month and talk about a weird
animal in the world and this time I get
to talk about a weird animal who I know
personal in a way this is the animal who
inspired this idea because back many
years ago on scishow he came to visit me
and I won I looked for how you looked
younger too I freaked out because like
if a spaceship landed in my backyard and
this thing came out that would seem
perfectly normal
aside from there being a spaceship in my
backyard he is a prehensile-tailed
porcupines which there are many species
this is a Brazilian porcupine in
particular I have not ever seen anything
like that and even more specifically
this individual is Kemosabe who lives
with my friends Jesse and the gusto here
in Montana at animal wonders which is a
permanent home and safe haven for exotic
animals and native animals that can't
return to the wild
now Kimo is a bit of an internet
celebrity partially because of how he
looks there's just that giant tail and
there's all the spines and that very
good weird marshmallow nose but also
because of how he sounds now there are
cuter animals in the world but I don't
know if there are cuter sounding animals
let's take a minute just give it a
listen it's a little bit reminiscent of
like a baby cooing also of right but
they also just like sound kind of
human-like this is a noise that it would
be easy for me to make any hearing like
this human sound come out of this very
not human looking organism is you know a
little bit exhilarating it's very cute
it's also a little unsettling and those
emotions don't often come together in
the same time animal wonders has a
youtube channel at animal wonders
Montana that we actually helped produce
at complexly it's wonderful and so
adorable and you can learn so much go
subscribe to it there's links all over
the place wherever you might think you'd
find one now for a weird thing about
porcupines that word includes a number
of
different species they include the ones
that we have here in the US and also
down in Central and South America like
prehensile-tailed porcupines and then
there are the European and African and
Asian porcupines the old-world
porcupines and they are totally not
related I mean they are they're both
rodents but their quills evolved
separately they evolved from a common
ancestor that didn't have quills they're
only both called porcupines because
they're both spine pigs like pig pork
spine pine porcupine that's really where
their name comes from there are thorn
pigs good because their quills evolved
separately they actually function
completely differently and it isn't the
only time this has happened hedgehogs
and echidna also have spines that
evolved completely separately because
like it's just not a terrible idea to be
really unpleasant to bite
prehensile-tailed porcupines live in
trees that's why they have their
prehensile tails and they are very good
climbers indeed when a pork you pet is
born and yes that is the proper word for
a baby porcupine they are soft and fuzzy
and can't very well be carried around by
their big thorny mamas so they have the
same muscular tails and functioning
claws as their mamas and they can climb
from day one I'm very happy to have been
able to feature one of my good friends
in the bizarre beasts segment everybody
go subscribe to animal wonders the work
they do is amazing there are such
wonderful people and their videos are
very good and yes I know my company does
produce them I'm biased who cares thanks
everybody for a wonderful profit for
awesome we had over a thousand more
donors than we had in previous years we
beat all of our previous project for
awesome it was such an amazing time John
I'll see you on Tuesday